und bei mir im studio begrüße ich jetzt
dietmar bartsch stehen
fraktionsvorsitzenden der linken schönen
guten abend herr
herbert die sind sich in diesem konflikt
in einer frage mit der bundesregierung
einig als partei die linke nämlich
grundsätzlich keine waffenlieferungen in
die ukraine ins krisengebiet anders
sieht es aus bei weitergehenden
sanktionen oder bei strafmaßnahmen auch
da sagen sie auf keinen fall sollte man
das anwenden was wäre im ernstfall dann
ihre antwort an russland was für
konsequenzen hätte russland von ihrer
seite zu befürchten also man muss jetzt
alles tun dass eine konsequente
entspannungs politik gemacht wird
deeskalation ist das gebot der stunde
und da sind waffenlieferungen natürlich
das völlig falsche es geht darum einen
krieg zu verhindern und da muss
zuallererst verbal abgerüstet werden
aber dann auch praktisch das muss das
ziel sein und nicht waffen liefern weil
das heißt ja waffen wären ja nicht als
ansichtsexemplare dahin geschickt
sondern um angewendet zu werden und das
muss man verhindern atommacht russland
die gefahren europa was das auslösen
könnte deshalb finde ich es richtig dass
jetzt viel geredet wird dass der kanzler
in die ukraine nach russland fährt das
ist vernünftig das scheint momentan noch
nicht besonders viel zu bringen
waffenlieferungen stehen ja auch gar
nicht zur debatte momentan das hat noch
einmal die frage welche weitergehenden
konsequenzen würden sie denn auch sich
der linken russland an drohen wenn es in
der ukraine einmarschieren sollte stehen
da zum beispiel auch sanktionen auf dem
plan es geht darum zu verhindern dass es
ein krieg gibt sanktionen haben wir seit
20 14 was sie gebracht haben sehen wir
ich glaube nicht dass drohen hilft
sondern es hilft dialog eine kluge
entspannungs politik da ist es richtig
das ist jetzt das nato russland gespräch
wieder geführt wird da ist die osze eine
wichtige organisation
es geht nur deeskalation denn frieden in
europa gibt es nur mit russland und
nicht gegen russland das bedeutet im
ernstfall wenn russland einmarschiert
hat es von seiten der linken nicht mehr
zu befürchten als weitere diskussionen
als weiteren dialog verstehe ich sie
richtig glauben sie ich gehe davon aus
dass man alles tun muss das zu
verhindern wer redet dann immer davon
aus russland einmarschiert
ja wir müssen alles tun dass das
verhindert wird wenn zu sagen was was
ist dann wenn der russe vor berlin steht
da können wir auch mal drüber reden so
ein unsinn ein gegenteilig frieden ist
das gebot der stunde deeskalation und
nicht weder verbales noch reales
aufrüsten und deswegen sind waffen
falsch deswegen muss russland seine
truppen abziehen deswegen muss man das
sehr deutlich aussprechen aber keine
frage es ist ja nicht so dass da keine
kritik gegenüber russland geübt wird
darum geht es nicht aber kriegs
verhinderung deeskalation keine waffen
dass es notwendig und ich wünsche mir im
übrigen gleiche maßstäbe überall ich
höre kein wort von unserer
aussenministerin wenn in syrien von der
türkei aktuell bombardiert wird komisch
ein anderer konflikt da würde auch gerne
mit ihnen jetzt noch im moment bei der
ukraine haben denn aus ukrainischer
sicht stellt sich das ganze ja doch sehr
ernst da da da steht dass russische
truppen kontingent tatsächlich direkt
vor der grenze es gibt zahlreiche belege
dafür dass die ukraine auf drei seiten
praktisch umzingelt ist und die ukraine
die ukrainische regierung wünscht sich
starke partner an ihrer seite die ein
deutliches stopp zeichen setzen was ist
er stoppzeichen gegenüber moskau also
wenn ich herrn selensky richtig
verstanden habe hat er in der letzten
woche gesagt dass sich die situation gar
nicht so verändert hat und dass er dafür
plädiert das nicht eskaliert wird das
wären diese aussage schon mehrfach
relativiert und eingeordnet hat ja aber
nochmal auch bei herrn selensky er wird
sich mit putin hoffentlich im normandie
format demnächst mit herrn scholz mit
herrn mack rom treffen das ist der weg
und drohen ich sage nochmal drohen hilft
nicht wir haben will das deutlich sagen
wir haben sanktionen seit 2014 und als
jemand der einige jahre dort gelebt hat
in diesem land kann ich nur sagen wir
einmal einen neunten mal erlebt hat und
erlebt hat wie das war für die 27
millionen toten russen ukraine die
völker der sowjetunion betrauert sieht
der weiß dass aus deutschland nicht über
drohungen geredet werden sollte sondern
nur über deeskalation die linke bleibt
bei dem konzept dialog als einziges
mittel in dieser situation
vielen dank für dieses gespräch dank
ging